[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonvaux le monde
beaucoup cachette comment aider la
population z les biens mal et mieux
alors donnez pas sorti de l'auberge
aujourd'hui on est où on est à sainte
suzanne à sainte suzanne on ne va pas
voir susan non non on va voir hubert
l'ubs est en fête et là des cacaotiers
non-match cacao écart qui aurait fait
quoi avec chocolat mais pas que les
enfants on va apprendre aujourd'hui
exactement cause à effet avec cacao
comment ça se fait que notre cacao la
réunion etc etc et vous allez me suivre
parce qu'on a envie de tout apprendre à
les voler
[Musique]
je chante
du bonheur oui au thème rouge baroudeur
oui mais nathan là où l'on joué bien
bonjour comment ça va bien ça va ça va
mais on espère du mois déjà merci de
nous appuyer chez toi c'est tout naturel
alors on est où ben là on est dans rue
marchande village de nour yves
dassonville à gérer
et sur un terrain qui est un champ de
cannes voilà trente ans draps voilà 35
ans on est venu pourquoi mon chèr hubert
ben stiller si j'en crois
ce dont tu m'as parlé au téléphone on
est venu vous êtes venu pour que nous
parlions de cacao de cette relance du
cacao à la veille c'est exactement ça
moi tu sais ce qu'on va faire on va
rentrer tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet on y va on y va alors allé à
l'envi
[Musique]
alors là je vais te montrer
l'un des premiers arbres cacaoyer qui
ont été plantés
vraisemblablement c'est qu'un courriel a
été planté en 80 puisque je suis parti
en 80 il était planté qui introduit le
cacao la réunion et pourquoi alors le
cacao à la réunion a été introduit par
un grand maître des introductions joseph
hubert dans son petit dans sa propriété
de bras mussard à saint benoît d'accord
les premiers cacaoyers qui sont arrivés
ici sont arrivés en 1777
c'était une épice comme le pauvre comme
le giro qu est ce ce gir offre ce poivre
cela muscade tout ça est introduit par
joseph hubert ici d'accord c'est pour ça
que joseph hubert et pierre poivre sont
les personnages éminemment important
dans notre région tu sais quoi je veux
tu me montres une cabosse assez possible
ah non je vais te montrer plusieurs à
plusieurs niveaux
monsieur là il connaît tout est paralysé
par les essais libres il dit que l'été
tu dis cacao dans la peau de 25 jours
[Musique]
hubert je rêve mais notre espagne et à
bosse là voilà tu es en phase une
cabosse sur un arbre que je voulais te
montrer parce que il illustre tout à
fait les problèmes du cacaoyer cette
variété là est une des plus sensibles
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
conseille de le mettre en agroforesterie
c'est-à-dire avec d'autres arbres afin
de limiter les attaques d'insectes qui
sont susceptibles de nuire à sa
prospérité d'accord en ce qui nous
concerne dans l'aspect de relance de
cacao que l'on veut faire c'est une
cacao de qualité dont la rareté lui
attribue une un prix particulier et dont
les confiseurs les chocolatiers
considère que c'est parmi les meilleurs
au monde donc premier premier visite là
on va voir donc petite leçon sur la
cabosse et juste après on va faire il
est conflictuelle dans la pépinière ok
c'est bizarre c'est bon pas fait
[Musique]
on passe sur les cabosses je parlais
tout à l'heure des cinq pétales de
cabosses si vous regardez celle ci n'est
pas tout à fait mûre elle est encore
dans sa couleur pourpre de naissance
quand elle est mûre elle devient dans
quelle poule elles elles commencent à
jaunir à l'intérieur des rainures l
extrémité un peu comme la vanille et je
parlais tout à l'heure des cinq pétales
si on regarde bien en quand on ouvre les
fèves puis ce qu'on appelle faible et
graines qui sont à l'intérieur les faits
sont disposés les comme sir en épis de
maïs 5 colonnes de fèves 5 des ventes de
graines bon ben maintenant qu'on va
aller à la pépinière et on va on va voir
comment on se prépare à provisionner les
planteurs qui désirent se lancer dans
cette aventure
[Musique]
allons donc la pépinière
l'aréna tu as des magnifiques petits
plants de cacao c'est ça c'est ça c'est
ça la taille une seule variété de cacao
la seule variété c'est la seule variété
c'est la variété criollo de celle qui
est introduite par joseph hubert donc et
vraisemblablement ce sont les
descendants de ce que joseph hubert a
introduit ici dis moi je suppose que
c'est celle assez pour la vente ça c'est
pour la vente pour les planteurs qui à
qui on les propose on les propose à 50
euros à 5 euros le plan pour les 50
premiers 2 euros 50 ce qui nous payent à
peine on compte pas le temps des
bénévoles qui participent à ces
plantations mais ça paye à peine
le terreau est nécessaire à la
constitution de la terre de ses plans tu
as la passion du rugby
[Musique]
gg plus beaucoup de temps pour la boire
acquitté
à wuxi
[Musique]
pluie
[Applaudissements]
les faits me
les
[Musique]
les filles
je sais quoi ça sert à quoi alors ça
c'est ce sont des fèves qui ont
un âge différent bon jury que le toit
exactement celles ci sont les fèves qui
ont fait remonter pendant six jours
c'est-à-dire trois fois deux jours et
qui ont séché à l'ombre hier et qui
profite d'un peu de soleil mais j'ai mis
cette couverture transparente pour
protéger contre la pluie qui qui est
fréquente elles ont juste fermenter dans
la boue j'ai vraiment cette impression
d'avoir
d'avoir ce chocolat noir font
qu'y veste ou alors quand on fait du
chocolat chaud à boire ce goût de
chocolat qu'on n'ait pas de sucre
surtout se goûte masse et c'est là c'est
vraiment ça là j'ai l'impression qu'on
écrase on est un petit peu de sucre
dedans on croque du chocolat c'est
hallucinant fait de la publicité pour le
criollo de la réunion et pour le
chocolat qu'on pourra faire ou pour les
fèves que l'on pourra commercialiser
dans nos pharmacies où nos maisons diane
est
[Musique]
dis moi on n'a pas bon bien sûr il ya le
chocolat bon ça c'est le chocolat cacao
c'est évident mais dis moi est ce que il
ya d'autres propriétés cette fameuse
fève si vous croquer ses fèves là vous
avez vous pouvez quasiment vous passez
de manger mais il faut pas faire ça
toute la vie mais c'est un reconstituant
et un couffin les pharmacies vendent des
fèves de cacao à la réunion qui viennent
du honduras du guatemala et c'est
n'importe quoi et bien notre notre
première ambition à nous c'est de faire
en sorte pas de ruminer les gens du
guatemala et de l'en dehors mais de
faire en sorte que les fèves de cacao de
la réunion et le même sort que c'est fun
mais c'est évident on enfin un moynier
d'avions moins - tout cela au river
circuit comme fer que les circuits quoi
circuit réunionnais malouda
[Musique]
il faut venir voir hubert 1 parce qu'il
ya aussi des scènes y a pas que lui
d'ailleurs la réunion voilà encore un
donc et d'autres producteurs de 2,2 de
cacao en poudre de cacao en cacao un des
meilleurs du monde maman et mais achète
[Musique]
alors nous voilà installés sous la
véranda à londres après l'effort le
réconfort tranquille ou 10 mois alors je
un peu curieux un
doigt comment tu as commencé qu'est ce
qui t'a amené à t'intéresser au cacao
juste pour le plaisir parce que j'avais
constaté que l'ayant fait pas
incidemment une fois les gens étaient
intéressés par ce qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas alors cet aspect
pédagogique
c'est ce qui a été déclenché ce qui a
été le déclencheur de la volonté de
relancer n'ont pas la culture du cacao
mais la connaissance du cacao notre
intention était de plantes et de faire
planter dans les eaux les écoles
volontaires de faire chanter un cacaoyer
par les élèves de cp pour que ces
enfants du cp l'entretiennent l'année et
qu' ils suivent au gré de leur scolarité
la croissance de l'arbre pour voir
l'éclosion des fleurs et des cabosses à
l'issue de leur scolarité élémentaire si
tu dis là à les tuer un dernier mot à
dire qu'est ce que tu dirais concernant
cette activité qu'est-ce que tu devrais
aux gens qu est ce que tu es
professionnel qu'est ce que tu dirais
aux collectivités le cacao pays c'est si
ce n'est pas un as des milk c'est une
plante qui est là depuis longtemps qu'il
y a des terrains qui ne font rien et qui
sont propres la culture du cacao
les revenus du cacao on ne peut pas les
garantir
mais ce que l'on sait c'est que fille on
a une chocolaterie qui s'ouvre à la
réunion avec le matériel adéquat avec
une expérience adéquat on pourra avoir
une fabrication de chocolat plus roman
français puisque le cacao auraient été
cultivés sur un territoire français mais
gouttes moi je pense on a fait le tour
on n'a jamais fini avec le cacao on n'a
jamais fini mais on reviendra au qui
reviendra au quai m'écoute je te dis au
revoir merci beaucoup au revoir mais et
partager tes connaissances et au plaisir
d'avoir partagé ce moment parfait allez
nous trouvera à l'est ne tombent veloma
vélo oumar
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya des nippes autant est ce
qu'il ya des crocodiles et ben non on
les achète suzanne mes enfants
l'émission se termine promis je
reviendrai très vite vous voir alors moi
je remercie beaucoup hubert parce que
j'ai beaucoup appris aujourd'hui sur le
cacao je vous remercie vous de ne suivre
tous les dimanches nous dit au revoir
est très important marmailles on n'est
pas du tout sortis de l'auberge nom de
patron de l'auberge parce que - la
découverte de l'auberge me savard
directeur millions bas de la vie mange
mange du cochon il mange bouchon cacao
non il existe pas
[Musique]